hi there Steve coffin here to talk about
language learning and I'm going to do a
little differently I'm going to do it on
my iPad and I'm going to talk about why
you don't need to remember vocabulary
you just need to enjoy the language If
We Gather lots of words and phrases and
bits of the language into our brain they
go into sort of a memory Reserve even if
you can't remember them you can't
retrieve them it doesn't matter you
enjoy it you know when you're learning a
language you can't really keep track of
your progress I just finished doing my
kettlebell routine here you know with
these kettlebells here and I have no
sense of did I get stronger or anything
but I enjoy doing it I feel good after
I've done it I know that cumulatively
it's good for me so it's the same when
you're listening and reading and you're
putting stuff into your memory Reserve
you can't remember don't try to remember
it eventually the words will stick
that's my advice
you want more information about language
learning go to my blog the linguist.com